ouah quel bus pourraient très vite y
prendre goût ouais les gars j'ai un
château
il a des rêves très ordinaire au fond un
petit rhume
oui
ce jour-là il cherchait juste un endroit
où se cacher et là il a été frappé
une cuillère bits et dans cette tour
depuis très longtemps j'ai un marché à
vous proposer un marché
regardez par ici
je veux voir le monde et pas seulement
depuis ma fenêtre
il a d'abord répondu impossible puis il
a dit lance moi ta chez eux ils m'aiment
pas ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en ce
moment personne ne m'aime je vois bien
qu'ils n'aient pas du tout à fait avec
vous même chez une soeur et leur musique
qu'il faut protéger qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
on veut la fille aux cheveux magiques oh
je veux la même c'est absolument génial
mangin série jambes écartées jean
maccurdy jambes écartées
j'ai attendu ce jour là toute ma vie je
commence à douter de ce que j'ai imaginé
et si je m'étais trouvé mais voilà ouais
je rêve où j'étais en train de me battre
en duel contre un cheval a passé son
fétiche
décidément c'est pas mon jour d'habitude
ça marche à tous les coups a accompli
son rêve compte sur moi ton rêve il est
nu c'est à elle que je parle